[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight the Russia investigation
if you can remember that far back was
created to expose collusion between
American politicians and operatives from
foreign governments and since so far the
investigation has simply exposed itself
as corrupt and mismanaged newly released
text messages from FBI agent Peter
struck suggest high-level FBI operatives
were not on the level about the
investigation from the very beginning
fox chief intelligence correspondent
catherine herridge joins us now with
details catherine well thank you Tucker
the text messages are a window into the
FBI's highly charged internal politics
under then director James Comey and
suggests at least one senior
investigator was skeptical the Russia
probe would uncover wrongdoing
two days after special counsel Robert
Muller took over the probe in May now
demoted FBI agent Peter struck and now
reassigned FBI lawyer Lisa Paige
discussed the merits of joining Muller's
team struck tails Paige you and I both
know the odds are nothing if I thought
it was likely I be there no question I
hesitate in part because of my gut sense
and concerned there's no big there there
in another more cryptic text struck
rights I personally have a sense of
unfinished business Unleashed it with my
ethat stands for mid-year exam the FBI's
code name for the Clinton email case and
now I need to fix it and finish it
another Republican who read the text
said the FBI officials talk about a
secret society within days of President
Trump's victory there was a society of
at least two people to include Peter
struck and Lisa page that had a desire
to keep Donald Trump from becoming
president and then an expressed intent
to work against him after he was elected
president the FBI blames a technical
problem for a five-month gap in the
struck page text and would not comment
to Fox News and whether the bureau has
taken physical custody of their phones
for a forensic review that could recover
those texts Tucker
Kathryn Harris thanks for always being
on this show digenova
is a former US attorney in DC and he
joins us tonight Joe thanks for coming
up my pleasure
so on special report a little over an
our ago ron johnson that had a senator
who's head of the homeland security
committee suggested that the secret
society referenced in these texts may
have been an actual thing and it may
have met off-site away from the FBI
secretly we don't know more than that
what does this suggest to you it
suggests as we've said from the
beginning that there was a brazen plot
to illegally exonerate Hillary Clinton
and if she didn't win the election to
then frame Donald Trump with a falsely
created crime everything that we have
seen from these texts and from all the
facts developing shows that the FBI and
senior DOJ officials conspired to
violate the law and to deny Donald Trump
his civil rights what would be the
motive for that the motive would be that
they didn't like Donald Trump they
didn't think he was fit to be President
and they were going to do everything
within their power to exonerate Hillary
Clinton and if she lost to frame Donald
Trump with a false crime because they
didn't think he should be President what
do you make of the claim that five
months of text messages between Strock
and Lisa page from someone have
disappeared as Lois Lerner's emails did
as Hillary Clinton emails well as an old
United States attorney who has watched
obstruction of justice is over the years
that explanation from the bureau is
ludicrous those texts were either
purposely destroyed period they were
purposely destroyed what moreover they
exist somewhere I can assure you the NSA
has them other companies have them
Verizon has them AT&T and if the bureau
can't figure out how to get them they're
in worse shape than I thought they were
so you don't buy it at all no no
absolutely not they're those texts exist
and if they don't exist they were
destroyed so you suggest this is
obstruction of justice
how do we proceed if the countries chief
law enforcement agency is itself guilty
of that well the Attorney General needs
to appoint a special counsel and if he
doesn't want to do that he needs to make
sure that the criminal division of the
Justice Department and panels a grand
jury immediately and start starts
putting in that grand jury under oath
Comey struck a
baker mccabe everybody is and senior
Justice Department officials Sally Yates
Bruce or and others john carlin the head
of the National Security Division
all of these people need to be in front
of a federal grand jury we have long
since past the time when we need to have
just congressional investigations for
this that make no mistake about it a
group of FBI and DOJ people were trying
to frame Donald Trump of a falsely
created crime is there any possibility
the Justice Department has already
impaneled that investigation why
certainly hope so because we're long
past the time when that should have been
done I hope they have if they haven't I
can't imagine that they're not about to
do so shortly why is it so hard for the
FBI to respond to legitimate and lawful
requests for information from the
Congress which provides oversight it
shouldn't be I don't understand it III
must say 'christopher raised performance
has been extremely unimpressive with
regard to how to lead an agency at a
time of crisis how to respond publicly
how to respond to Congress how to carry
out your duties it has been an abysmal
performance by director Ray strucken
page apparently still working at the FBI
headquarters here in Washington does
that strike he was odd strikes me is
very odd I cannot conceive of
circumstances under which agents in
these conditions with the kind of text
messages that they exchanged knowing
what we know now about the criminal
activity involving the compromising of
National Security Agency intercepts of
702 data involving involving private
American citizens I can't imagine how
they can still be on the premises would
they be cleared to see classified
information I certainly cannot imagine
how they would still be clear to see
close they have access to former
colleagues of course over there their
present colleagues in the building yes
members of the secret society no doubt
continue to still talk to one another
what can be I mean are there civil
service Robin how could that be
at this point I'm afraid only
Christopher ray knows why they are being
allowed to stay in that building and
last question since you have been here
for a long time and worked in this world
for a long time are we right to have
real questions about the integrity of
our justice system watching this
regrettably we are at a point now where
the FBI has lost almost all of its
credibility and
credibly its integrity as a role of the
result of the conduct of James Comey who
remains America's most dirty cop
terrifying judges Jonah thank you very
much for that thank you